la inequidad en el acceso a las vacunas
anchico vie 19 es una amenaza para todos
ese fue el mensaje de activistas de
organizaciones como oxfam y amnistía
internacional para los líderes del g20
que se reúnen en oro hma sus peticiones
hacen eco de una carta firmada por un
centenar de ex líderes mundiales
dirigida al primer ministro italiano
mario draghi que insta al g20 a
distribuir el excedente de sus vacunas
según ellos eeuu la unión europea reino
unido y canadá acumularían 240 millones
de dosis no utilizadas
no sería ético que se desperdiciarán
todas estas vacunas cuando en el mundo
hay 10.000 muertes diarias por joven 19
muchas de las cuales podrían ser
evitadas a principios de este mes la
organización mundial de la salud
estableció el objetivo de vacunar al
menos al 40 por ciento de la población
de todos los países para el fin de año
pero en algunas partes del mundo esto no
parece realista áfrica tiene la tasa de
vacunación más lenta de todos los
continentes ya que sólo el 8.4 por
ciento de la población ha recibido al
menos una dosis alrededor del 76 por
ciento de las vacunas se han
administrado en países de ingresos altos
y medio altos frente al 0.5 por ciento
en los de ingresos bajos las naciones
más pobres dependen de un acuerdo de
repartición de vacunas llamado kóvacs
que tuvo que recortar sus previsiones de
dosis varias veces debido a problemas de
producción y al acaparamiento de vacunas
por parte de los países ricos muchos de
los cuales ya están ofreciendo dosis de
refuerzo o tercera dosis
hoy en día el número de refuerzos que se
está administrando en todo el mundo
cerca de un millón de inyecciones al día
es tres veces mayor que la cantidad de
vacunas que se administran en los países
de bajos ingresos es decir alrededor de
330.000 dosis diarias
hasta ahora se han donado
261 millones de dosis a los países en
desarrollo lejos de los 1800 millones
prometidos